bonjour bienvenue dans Parlement Hebdo
bonjour Michael nous allons faire
ensemble le tour de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
et on commence avec Manuel Valls qui a
détaillé son plan de 50 milliards
d'économistes étaient mercredi en
Conseil des ministres gel des
prestations sociales jusqu'en 2015 tout
en préservant les minima sociaux l'État
est à la diète et les fonctionnaires
seront mis sa contribution de son côté
l'UMP prépare les européennes la droite
espère capitalisée après son succès aux
élections municipales mais quelle
campagne menée alors que le parti est
divisé sur l'avenir et la vision de
l'Europe enfin le plus de l'hebdo cette
semaine s'intéresse au spin doctors ces
conseillé en communication des hommes
politiques un documentaire Les a suivi
en coulisses à découvrir à la fin de
l'émission cette semaine Luc Chatel
bonjour bonjour vous êtes vice-président
délégué de l'UMP député de la Marne et
anciens
ministre de l'Éducation entre autres
alors c'est une tradition dans cette
émission on va laisser la parole aux
députés qui vont parler un petit peu de
vous et puis bien sûr vous réagirez
juste après
d'entre nous il a ses qualités ses
défauts comme tout être humain mais
c'est un garçon très bien voilà c'est un
homme posé
sage
qui réfléchit aux questions de fond
dans notre République est Assailly comme
quelqu'un qui croit je pense à ce qu'il
fait qui essaye de ne jamais être dans
l'outrance et voilà moi j'ai toujours
plaisir à débattre avec lui
voilà du respect je l'ai vu à l'oeuvre
et une grande hauteur de vue quand il
prend la parole dans les réunions
voilà c'est ils sont pas tellement
nombreux dans la nouvelle génération à
avoir une telle auteur de vue en plus
c'est un garçon qui est qui est fidèle
en amitié et ça compte aussi intelligent
travailleur et il doit juste être un peu
moins européen
parce que à mon avis il se trompe il
faut qu'il revise sa copie en matière
d'Europe et beaucoup plus réaliste
on va en parler évidemment mais
j'entends beaucoup sage c'est vrai quand
on voit sur les bancs de l'Assemblée
nationale de temps en temps les gens qui
s'envoient des noms d'oiseaux vous c'est
assez rare quand même vous c'est pas
possible
d'abord un chacun son caractère ensuite
quand on approche de l'âge que je vais
atteindre cette année on doit gagner en
sagesse non voilà moi j'aime la
politique pour
la défense de ces convictions mais
surtout pour l'action moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de faire des choses en
politique c'est pas d'être là pour être
là de s'accrocher des responsabilités ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de faire avancer
les dossiers puis de le faire en
respectant on n'a jamais raison tout
seul contre les autres moi j'ai été
élevé à la mode du monde de l'entreprise
dans lequel on travaille en équipe dans
lequel ce qui compte c'est le résultat
dans lequel on n'a jamais tout seul dans
son coin raison tout seul dans son coin
voilà c'est un peu les valeurs les les
règles qui guident mon engagement
politique dialogue encore une fois
dialogue c'est plus important
travail efficacité voilà c'est alors
justement dans quelques semaines les
Français choisiront leur députés
européens après la vague bleue des
municipales l'UMP espère concrétiser
mais l'Europe c'est un sujet qui divise
au sein de l'UMP quel avenir qu'elle
perspective elle a question n'est pas
tout à fait tranchée alors comment le
l'UMP se prépare-t-elle à quelques
semaines des élections germandrie
à quelques semaines du scrutin du MP SPR
une nouvelle vague bleue pour les
élections européennes et cherche aussi à
afficher l'unité aucune ligne directrice
pour le moment le dossier n'est pas
nouveau il s'agit de réconcilier les
fédéralistes et les eurosceptiques la
ligne directrice on va l'avoir on est
dans cette période du débat de la
discussion et dans les 15 jours qui
viennent la ligne sera calée et tout le
monde se rassemblera sur cette sur cette
ligne vous savez il y a des sensibilités
différentes c'est l'essence même de
l'UMP il n'y a pas de gens à l'UMP qui
se réclament
du souverainisme façon on quitte
l'Europe ce qu'on entend aux Front
national ou à l'extrême gauche donc
c'est pas un discours anti-européen par
contre c'est pas un discours euro ba une
seule consigne officielle sera semblée
pour obtenir un maximum de sièges de
redécuté alors sur les listes toutes les
sensibilités sont mélangées mais
difficile voire impossible de battre le
record des dernières élections au niveau
national l'UMP le Nouveau Centre avait
alors obtenu plus de 27% des voix soit
29 d'euros députés sur 72 il n'y aura
pas de monétise monolitisme il y aura
des divergences parce que aujourd'hui on
est dans une période transitoire où il y
a une prise de conscience que cette
union européenne va imposer et que deux
les solutions et bien il faut en
débattre et bien tant mieux si
aujourd'hui il y a des bas au sein du MP
quand on
nomme monsieur la Massour que je
respecte profondément dont je respecte
les opinions mais qui incarnent qui a
toujours incarné une ligne fédéraliste
une ligne qui qui veut que l'Europe
continue comme elle fonctionne comme
elle se construit
majoritaire elle a commencé à s'affirmer
et elle sera concrétisée la semaine
prochaine puisque nous présenterons avec
nos têtes de liste aux élections
européennes la ligne de notre mouvement
pour ces élections
je vous pose juste celle-ci c'est des
propositions qui sortent d'un livre un
retour à une Europe des 6 top à la folie
normative l'Europe et le plus grand
échec du 20e siècle vous savez qu'il y a
ça
j'ai une petite idée Laurent
quand même c'est une figure importante
de l'UMP est une position
européenne quand même c'est une position
solitaire nous avons une position
majoritaire d'abord revenir à un débat
fédéraliste contre souverainiste c'est
revenir 20 ans en arrière aujourd'hui
plus personne à l'UMP ne propose des
États-Unis d'Europe et plus personne ne
propose de revenir comme je l'ai entendu
à l'instant à une position que ce que
disait pierre Lelouch totalement
souverainiste non simplement nous avons
à défendre une position majoritaire par
exemple moi il y a des choses que je
considère comme non négociables dans
notre position européenne l'axe
franco-allemand l'axe franco-allemand
nous ne pouvons pas le brader ça n'est
pas possible et il serait quand même en
question c'est une position encore une
fois minoritaire la position
vous verrez quand nous défendrons la
position de l'UMP mais quand vous
entendez les voies de l'UMP aussi bien
les anciens premiers ministres Alain
Juppé François Fillon Jean-Pierre
Raffarin ils sont quelque part cette
position elle est l'héritage de 25 ans
d'engagement européen courageux parfois
de s'attendre responsable politique je
pense à Jacques Chirac qui a su en son
temps prendre une position européenne
alors qu'on sait très bien qu'ils
historiquement c'était pas forcément
dans ces gènes vous aviez fait des
élections municipales une sorte de test
grandeur nature sur la politique menée
par François Hollande là cette fois ces
européennes c'est un test quoi sur
Manuel Valls par exemple c'est un test
évidemment politique tout élection
nationale
un enjeu politique y compris pour le
gouvernement en place et c'est vrai que
si à nouveau l'opposition remportait
nette victoire et que le parti de
gouvernement se retrouvait ce qui
pourrait être le cas troisième dans ces
élections ce serait une deuxième claque
pour le gouvernement en place donc bien
sûr c'est un rendez-vous politique mais
c'est aussi un rendez-vous dans lequel
nous voulons défendre nos convictions et
sur l'Europe si vous voulez c'est
important parce que c'est un vrai sujet
entre le gouvernement et nous au moment
où on a un gouvernement qui tourne le
dos à l'Europe qui défie les
institutions européennes le discours de
politique générale de Manuel Valls
c'était une défiance vis-à-vis de la
Commission de Bruxelles en disant
attendez nous on va prendre le temps il
y a le temps de la Commission européenne
mais il y a aussi le temps des français
c'était une défiance nous avons un
gouvernement qui pendant deux ans a
président de la République qui a tourné
le dos à l'Allemagne qui a défié la
chancelière allemande et bien dans cette
période nous nous devons incarner
un pôle en faveur de la construction
européenne et un pôle franchement ancré
dans nos relations françaises du Parti
socialiste je vous propose d'aller au
mardi avec le Parti socialiste qui a un
nouveau patron
il y a eu le remaniement au gouvernement
il y a eu aussi un remaniement à
l'Élysée voilà donc que le Parti
socialiste a un nouveau patron s'appelle
Jean-Christophe gambadéliste on l'écoute
les militants nous ont dit
occupez-vous de nous
et bien ce sera
ma feuille de route
c'est le type de PS que je veux
construire un parti socialiste
rassemblé combatif inventif
parfois
insolent question quand même parce que
c'est important c'est l'homologue de
Jean-François Copé c'est un peu
évidemment un animal beaucoup plus
politique car l'amdésira il vous fait
peur Jean-Christophe Cambadélis ou pas
bon il me fait pas peur quand j'entends
un chef de partie expliqué qu'il faut
qu'il s'occupe de ces militants ça à la
fois ça me fait sourire et ça me désole
si vous voulez le sujet c'est pas de
s'occuper des militants avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour les militants le
sujet c'est de s'occuper des problèmes
des Français voilà c'est ça la question
c'est comment aujourd'hui le Parti
socialiste le gouvernement et la
majorité de l'autre côté il y a un parti
qui a besoin aussi de ces militants
qu'on a besoin des militants
on nous avons besoin des militants pour
débattre pour porter l'action politique
c'est d'ailleurs ça fait partie de notre
Constitution mais le sujet est pas de
s'adresser aux militants qui représente
un millième du collectoral le sujet
c'est de s'adresser aux Français et de
répondre aux problèmes des Français or
on voit bien que le Parti socialiste est
empêtré dans les
errements
François Hollande depuis deux ans on
voit bien qu'il y a pas de ligne facile
un parti aussi quand on est parti
majoritaire
c'est encore plus difficile quand il y a
pas de cap à la tête de l'État et nous
nous étions dans la partie du
gouvernement ou le moindre et le moins
plaisir c'est qu'il y avait un chef et
qu'elle a un cap alors on peut nous dire
ensuite oui mais du coup le parti
majoritaire il est sur le doigt sur la
petite coup de la couture du pantalon
mais au moins il y avait une ligne et il
y avait un parti qui défendait l'action
du gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est quoi
la ligne et d'ailleurs on le voit bien
avec la nomination de Manuel Valls on a
déjà plusieurs allers-retours en
quelques jours sur la question des
finances publiques sur la question
européenne donc je me mets la place de
Jean-Christophe Cambadélis c'est
vraiment du boulot
respect pour qu'on Christophe Cambadélis
c'est pas le sujet c'est sûr que passer
derrière Harlem Désir sans doute doit-il
se dire qu'il ne peut que mieux faire
dans son discours de politique générale
Manuel Valls a proposé
d'assouplir la réforme des rythmes
scolaires vous connaissez bien le sujet
dès les premières questions gouvernement
l'opposition a donc sauté sur l'occasion
pour demander le report de l'application
de la semaine de 4 jours et demi mais le
ministre de l'Éducation a réaffirmé
qu'elle s'appliquerait bien à tout le
monde à la rentrée prochaine écoutez cet
échange justement dans l'hémicycle du
député udi Franck régné et la réponse de
Benoît Ham monsieur le Premier ministre
dans votre déclaration de politique
générale la semaine dernière vous nous
avez déclaré qu'un assouplissement du
cadre des rythmes scolaires était à
prévoir donc votre déclaration vous
reconnaissiez aussi à travers cette
annonce pleine de lucidité que cette
réforme a provoqué de véritables
troubles dans nos territoires chez les
enseignants chez les agents territoriaux
et chez les parents d'élèves Monsieur le
Premier Ministre repoussé la mise en
œuvre de votre réforme des rythmes
scolaires nous avons décidé de mettre en
œuvre cette réforme et elle s'appliquera
bien comme le Premier ministre à la
rentrée 2014 nous avons constaté comme
vous et en toute bonne foi que des
difficultés existaient et il me semble
et il se serait dans le déni que de ne
pas considérer que sa difficulté existe
et le Premier ministre c'est donc engagé
à ce qu'il y ait des gestes justement à
la mise en œuvre de cette réforme je lui
ferai des propositions sous une dizaine
de jours à partir de la concertation que
j'ai commencé avec les organisations
d'enseignants avec les parents d'élèves
et avec les élus salut que vous me
connaissez bien vous avez été ministre
de l'éducation nationale que faut-il
faire de cette réforme il faut
simplement donner la liberté aux
communes voilà
en 2008 vous aviez renoncé au retour à
la semaine de quatre jours et demi
pourtant il y avait des rapports la
conférence nationale sur les rythmes
scolaires
simplement renoncer au retour à quatre
jours et demi la conférence nationale
sur les rythmes scolaires en 2011
demandait justement ce retour de à
quatre jours et demi mais j'étais très
attaché je l'avais dit à l'époque à un
principe qui est la liberté
on oublie de dire qu'en 2008 lorsqu'elle
Xavier Darcos nous avons mis en place la
semaine de quatre jours la règle
générale c'était les quatre jours mais
les communes qui le décidé après avis
des conseils d'école avait la
possibilité de repasser au 4 jours et
demi certaines villes l'ont fait la
ville de Toulouse par exemple est
repassée en 2010 à la semaine de 4 jours
et demi après avis des conseils d'école
donc si vous voulez j'entends du
gouvernement enfin de la sagesse on
parlait tout à l'heure oui parce que
quel gâchis le gouvernement c'est entêté
pendant 18 mois sur ce sujet et Monsieur
Peillon a réussi la prouesse de partir
d'une unanimité sur le principe de la
réforme pour aboutir à uneanimité contre
la mise en oeuvre de la réforme donc
quel gâchis donc j'entends enfin de la
part de Monsieur Val c'est du nouveau
ministre de l'Éducation une écoute et
j'entends une ouverture
ça veut dire enterrement ou pas
j'attends de savoir ce que c'est
pourquoi il s'agit la meilleure façon
encore une fois de s'en sortir c'est la
liberté pourquoi la liberté parce
qu'elle vous avez des communes qui ont
déjà mis en oeuvre cette réforme à la
rentrée dernière de gauche comme de
droite c'est pas un sujet politique
qui sont en train de la mettre en œuvre
moi je préside pour encore quelques
jours l'agglomération de Chaumont et
bien nous avons préparé la mise en œuvre
de cette réforme pour la rentrée
prochaine c'est insoluble insolu
pourquoi parce que c'est un surcoût de
je faisais le point hier avec le nouveau
maire de Chaumont 800000 euros 800000
euros c'est un point et demi au départ
je pensais que c'était un point et demi
de fiscalité supplémentaire aujourd'hui
il y a trois points de fiscalité dans
l'agglomération de chameau ça veut dire
qu'on va augmenter de 50% pour une
réforme donc qui n'évolue ni par les
parents ni par les enseignants et dont
permettez-moi de douter de l'efficacité
sur les élèves parce qu'on va leur faire
faire deux fois une heure et demie
d'activité périscolaires par semaine
avec des animateurs dont on sait qu'ils
n'auront pas été forcément bien formés
donc qui seront dans ces situations très
précaires bref quel gâchis
ça passera forcément par une
augmentation des impôts locaux
éventuellement si on doit payer cette
mesure le gouvernement se montre
autoritaire et qu'il transfère de
manière autoritaire sans ressources
cette compétence forcément il y aura des
endroits où ça se traduira par une
augmentation de la fiscalité forcément
parce que les communes sont exagues
c'est-à-dire sur ce point cette semaine
le Premier ministre a annoncé qu'il
irait bien 60 000 embauches
supplémentaires dans la fonction
publique et donc dans l'école bonne ou
mauvaise nouvelle pour vous mauvaise
nouvelle c'est un domaine dans lequel le
gouvernement s'entête il s'entête il
s'enferme dans son dogmatisme de
François Hollande oui enfin écoutez si
au moins celle-ci il avait pu ne pas la
tenir il y a beaucoup de promesses de
François Hollande qui n'ont pas été
tenues alors je comprends que au moment
où sont annoncés le gel de l'indice de
la fonction publique au moment où sont
annoncés un plan d'austérité pour la
fonction publique il faille envoyer un
message au fonctionnaires c'est le
contre message dit pourquoi parce que il
n'y a pas besoin de recruter 60000
emplois dans l'éducation il y a
aujourd'hui plus d'enseignants par élève
qui en avait il y a 20 ans dans le
système éducatif donc c'est un faux
problème ensuite parce que et d'ailleurs
monsieur Peillon l'avait lâché par une
advertance si vous recrutez davantage de
fonctionnaires vous aurez encore moins
de marge de manœuvre pour payer les
actuels fonctionnaires alors que nous
nous pensons qu'il faut moins de
fonctionnaires mieux rémunérés mieux
former mieux préparer à leur mission et
donc c'est notre philosophie Luc
châtaigne non pas ce mercredi justement
le plan d'économie de Manuel Valls
et justement une semaine après son
discours de politique générale Manuel
Valls a présenté son large plan
d'économie on va regarder les détails
avec Elisa Bartholomé
il est venu assurer lui-même la
promotion de son plan d'économie Manuel
Valls en personne a présenté les détails
de ce fameux plan les 11 milliards
d'euros d'économies a réalisé sur les
dépenses de protection sociale n'est pas
question évidemment de diminuer le
montant des prestations sociales mais
dans le contexte exceptionnel qui est le
nôtre elle ne seront pas revalorisées
jusqu'en octobre
2015 ces mesures temporaires
ce qui concerneuront pas les ménages
modestes mais ce ne sont pas les seuls
annonces de Manuel Valls le gel du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires sera
maintenu des réductions d'effectifs
auront lieu dans les agences de l'État à
l'exception de Pôle emploi et des
universités en revanche des emplois
continueront d'être créés dans les
secteurs sanctuarisés l'éducation
nationale la police et la justice pas de
remise en cause donc des 60000 postes
créés dans l'éducation nationale pas de
quoi satisfaire l'opposition qui profite
des questions au gouvernement pour
attaquer le Premier ministre ce matin
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous êtes
avancé mais vous vous êtes en réalité
dévoilée comme le premier ministre de la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat
souveraineté Monsieur le Premier
Ministre 50 milliards d'économies vous
le savez ne suffisent pas pas même à
couvrir le programme de stabilité c'est
près de 100 milliards d'économies qui
sont nécessaires qui seraient
nécessaires pour financer votre
politique quelques questions plus tard
Manuel Valls répond à la droite qui
l'attaque et à la gauche qui s'inquiète
l'effort demandé sera juste il ne s'agit
pas de mesure d'austérité il s'agit tout
simplement de gérer ce pays comme nous
le demande les Français en préservant en
maîtrisant la dépense publique et chacun
doit faire les efforts l'état
l'assurance maladie les prestations
sociales les collectivités territoriales
cet effort il sera juste il sera réparti
ces mesures seront présentées dans les
mois qui viennent dans les lois de
finance rectificative prévues avant
l'été puis cet automne dans le budget
le plan d'économie de Manuel Valls c'est
justement d'autres zooms de la semaine
avec nous Jean-Louis Gombaud bonjour
exactement alors la semaine dernière
vous vous plaignez il n'y avait pas
assez de précision sur les mesures
d'économies est-ce que vous y voyez plus
clair cette semaine est-ce que ça va
dans le bon sens je ne me plaignais pas
je faisais remarqué qu'effectivement et
il n'y avait pas assez d'économie mais
elle n'était pas assez détaillées et
précisé ma question monsieur le ministre
est la suivante qu'est-ce qui vous
ennuie dans ce plan de redressement des
finances publiques de Monsieur Valls
pour aller jusqu'à sans doute le rejeter
parce que en réalité c'est vrai que
c'est pas détaillé c'est les grosses
masses j'ai fait un petit calcul en gros
ce qui est à peu près sûr dans cette
affaire c'est la moitié c'est les 25
milliards d'euros donc à 25 milliards
qui mériteraient en date précisé mais
qui le seront d'ailleurs dans les
semaines qui viennent puisqu'il faudra
bien envoyer la copie à Bruxelles et
aussi au parlementaire donc passons sur
ce point si vous le voulez bien vous
avez un deuxième critique que j'ai
entendu vous dites il n'y a pas assez de
réforme structurelle nous nous sommes
pour des forme structurelle mais je
parle ici à l'élu qui était issue de
l'entreprise il sait bien que les
réformes structurelles ça coûte d'abord
et ça rapporte ensuite est d'ailleurs il
y aura sans doute quand on engagera la
réforme territoriale beaucoup de
désillusions sur ce plan les entreprises
d'ailleurs lorsqu'elles procède à des
restructurations elles font bien des
provisions pour restructuration parce
qu'elles savent bien que dans un premier
temps ça coûte de l'argent avant que
cela ne rapporte or on a une urgence
c'est évidemment
2017 et puis on vient d'entendre
monsieur Mariton qui nous dit vous
n'allez pas assez loin il s'agit de il
faudrait plutôt aller sur 100 milliards
d'euros d'économies et je me suis
effectivement reporté à la conférence de
presse qu'avait donné l'ancien Premier
ministre monsieur l'ancien ancien
Premier ministre monsieur Fillon il en
avait donné deux en août 2011 et en
novembre 2011 sur des plans de
redressement c'était très intéressant
parce que effectivement pour 2012 il
nous proposait un milliard 5 d'économies
un milliard 5 d'économies on est sur un
rythme aujourd'hui de 18 milliards et
ensuite effectivement il avait dit il
faut 100 milliards d'économies de 2012 à
2016 100 milliards de l'économies de
2012 à 2016 là nous sommes sur 50
milliards à préciser entre
2014-2014 et 2017 donc pardon 2015 et
2017 autrement dit on est à peu près à
peu près dans ce qu'avait prévu monsieur
Fillon lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il était à
la veille de quitter le pouvoir
2050 milliards entre 2004 et 2017 le
problème c'est que depuis 2012 on n'a
pas résorbé au contraire on a laissé
filer à nouveau et je viens à votre
première question la première question
vous dites mais finalement qu'est-ce qui
vous gêne moi ce qui me gêne c'est que
finalement ce plan il va mécontent tout
le monde c'est-à-dire que d'un côté on
fait l'austérité pour les Français on va
serrer la vis et de l'autre finalement
on ne règle pas le fond du problème
pourquoi on ne règle pas le fond du
problème parce que comme la évoqué Hervé
Mariton si vous voulez d'abord c'est 50
milliards d'euros ils ne veulent rien
dire ça coûte combien euros je ne suis
pas d'où il sorte c'est François
Hollande qui les a sorti mais si on veut
revenir au 3 % ce qui semble à nouveau
être l'objectif du gouvernement ça ne
l'a plus été pendant une semaine mais ça
semble à nouveau l'être depuis que ils
sont allés à Bruxelles si on veut
revenir aux 3%, il faut le refaire 57
milliards d'euros de d'économies 57 et
non pas 50 le Premier ministre a annoncé
vous l'avez cité Jean-Louis Gombaud
des dépenses supplémentaires dans son
discours de politique générale on estime
à environ 25 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires voilà donc ça veut dire
que l'effort pour revenir aux 3% c'est
pas 50 milliards c'est pas 25 c'est au
moins 80 milliards d'euros 82 milliards
d'euros or on voit bien que dans les
économies proposées par le Premier
ministre on n'est pas du tout à la
hauteur autre élément on nous parle
d'économie mais en fait ce sont des
annulations d'augmentation de dépenses
monsieur Fillon faisait exactement la
même chose et c'est admis par la
Commission européenne
par la Commission européenne que c'est
la bonne formule je crois que oui nous
avons fait des erreurs oui nous avons
pas nous n'avons pas réduit les déficits
comme il aurait fallu et nous avons
traversé une crise je rappelle que quand
les les recettes de l'État s'effondrent
en 2009 de 30% 30% des fondements des
recettes bah oui ça crée des déficits
donc oui nous n'avons pas résorbé les
déficits comme il aurait fallu mais
c'est pas pour ça que nous devons rester
nous enfermer dans cette logique et ne
pas réfléchir à agir autrement moi je
pense que l'enjeu des prochaines années
sera de redéfinir le périmètre
d'intervention de l'État on peut pas
continuer à raboter comme ça et c'est le
jeu dans lequel s'enferme monsieur Valls
où il va mécontenter tout le monde parce
que d'un côté il est obligé de bloquer
le point d'indice des fonctionnaires et
je lui donne raison donc il va
mécontenter toute cette base mais de
l'autre ce n'est pas du tout à la
hauteur de l'enjeu de réduction des
déficits et de réduction de la dépense
majeur donc nous nous pensons que
d'abord il faudra prendre des décisions
courageuses parce que ce que nous
annoncé monsieur Valls cette semaine
c'est un peu
pas ça c'est que c'est pas un plan
d'économie c'est la facture du manque de
courage de Monsieur Hollande depuis deux
ans voilà on paye les errements et le
manque de courage de François Hollande
donc il faudra que nous prenions des
décisions courageuses deux exemples deux
exemples que nous avons cité dans notre
projet les retraites on sait que sur les
retraites le gouvernement est allé à
180° à l'opposé de ce qu'il faudrait
faire nous nous préconisons c'est
difficile à dire aux Français mais je
pense que c'est nécessaire nous
préconisons 65 ans 44 ans de cotisations
ça ça rapporte de l'ordre de 20
milliards d'euros à horizon 2020
deuxièmement sur l'aide au logement on
voit bien qu'il y a une déperdition
monstrueuse sur l'aide au logement il
faudra réformer les logements avoir le
courage de baisser les dépenses
d'intervention écoutez on réussit quand
même le prouesse en France d'être le
pays où on a le plus d’être public au
logement et ou artificiellement on dope
le prix du marché et on rend les
logements inaccessibles à une grande
partie de nos concitoyens
merci Jean-Louis Gomo pour pour votre
analyse à laquelle bien évidemment le
Châtel a répondu et puis c'est dans ce
contexte que le patron du Medef pierre
Gattaz à Herman c'est l'idée d'un SMIC
jeune un SMIC au rabais transitoire pour
atteindre l'emploi écouter le une idée
serait de créer en effet intermédiaire
qui permettrait sur une face sur une
période déterminée transitoire
temporaire de pouvoir franchir cette
marge d'escalier par un échelon
intermédiaire temporaire et qui
permettrait à des personnes en
difficulté ou à des jeunes et bien de
monter d'un cran et surtout d'arrêter
d'être au chômage la France est le pays
d'Europe parmi les plus qui connaît un
taux des chômage parmi les plus élevés
et notamment chez les jeunes donc on
peut estimer légitimement que le SMIC
peut être une barrière à l'emploi et il
faut supprimer les barrières à l'emploi
cette vieille idée d'un SMIC jeune qui
au fond n'est rien d'autre que la
précarisation à nouveau de la jeunesse
ne me convient pas le gouvernement ne la
retiendra pas et donc j'en rediscuterai
avec les partenaires sociaux
il ne s'agit pas de tabou ou de
questions chaque il s'agit simplement de
l'intérêt des jeunes en question moi je
j'accorde trop d'importance à l'emploi
des jeunes pour céder aux facilités de
langage et parfois aux provocations un
peu inutile moi je pense que une fois de
plus l'emploi des jeunes mérite mieux
que cela alors vu que Châtel la droite
est divisée à ce sujet faut-il réformer
le SMIC pour la droite n'est pas divisée
la droite a pris une position très
claire après avoir eu un débat sur cette
question lorsque nous avons réuni notre
comité politique au mois de décembre
pour présenter notre projet d'alternance
nous avons dit que nous n'étions pas
favorables à une suppression du SMIC
pour les jeunes voilà mais nous avons eu
ce débat pourquoi nous avons eu du débat
parce que comme erikiotti le dit dans
votre partage il y a en France un
certain nombre de verrous de frein à
l'embauche on les connaît et
ont certains économistes expliquent que
le SMIC peut en faire partie que vous
avez des pays où vous avez par exemple
un SMIC régional
voilà donc nous avons eu ce débat mais
nous avons pensé que c'était un symbole
qui ne nous paraissait pas
audible et que il ne fallait pas revenir
sur cette question et qu'il y avait sans
doute d'autres moyens de déverrouiller
le marché du travail qui pouvait
rapporter aux jeunes justement cette
semaine François Hollande rencontrée ses
trois économistes qui ont écrit un livre
qui propose notamment une
régionalisation du SMIC
du coup ça veut dire que François
Hollande va peut-être travailler sur le
SMIC est-ce que ce sont des pistes de
réflexion selon vous est-ce qu'il faut
est-ce qu'il faut aller par là-bas
de courage par exemple excusez-moi mais
moi j'en ai assez des discours des
promesses et tout ce qui m'intéresse
c'est les actes voilà donc
j'ai entendu le Premier ministre vous
venez de montrer la l'ancienne
porte-parole de gouvernement
voilà donc je disais qu'il y a par
contre des domaines dans lequel on peut
déverrouiller le marché du travail en
particulier sous le contrat de travail
avec un contrat de travail unique
rechargeable qui permettrait plus de
souplesse pour les entreprises et ça ça
déverrouillerait le marché du travail
vous spécialiste aussi quand même un
homme libéral où il dit aussi humaniste
dans l'économie et dans la société voilà
la baisse du chômage ça passerait aussi
par des emplois
qu'on pourrait donner à plus de gens
sans les payer forcément au SMIC non je
pense que il doit y avoir des règles en
matière de salaire minimum je pense
simplement qu'il faut minimiser le
marché du travail voilà fluidifier
marche très ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il faut que ce soit plus simple
d'embaucher et plus simple de débaucher
les pays d'Europe regardez les pays
d'Europe c'est plus que la fin du séisme
c'est un contrat de travail unique
c'est-à-dire que vous n'avez vous sortez
posez-vous la question pourquoi 80% des
premiers emplois aujourd'hui chez les
jeunes ce sont des CDD pourquoi parce
que les entreprises ont tellement peur
d'avoir des problèmes de débaucher si
jamais l'activité se retourne si jamais
ils ont des difficultés que ils
préfèrent ne pas embaucher donc tout le
monde pédalait et pénalisé par ce
système vous avez dit tout à l'heure
vous préférez les actes vous avez
entendu Jean-Luc gombo sur les questions
économiques vous parlez évidemment de
problèmes de François Hollande dans la
politique aujourd'hui il y a une rumeur
il y a quelque chose qui est en train de
monter au niveau politique c'est l'idée
de la dissolution de l'Assemblée
nationale si jamais le gouvernement
tombait sur un des textes présenté vous
y croyez vous
vous faites bien de préciser si le
gouvernement tombait moi je ne crois pas
une dissolution en tout cas je ne ferais
pas ce procès François Hollande je
critique beaucoup François Hollande sur
beaucoup d'aspects de mettre en oeuvre
une dissolution de convenance je pense
que le seul la seule raison qui
motiverait une dissolution serait
effectivement tout simplement que le
gouvernement soit battu sur un texte
important c'est possible d'abord le
gouvernement les régulièrement au Sénat
on oublie de le dire mais sur votre
chaîne
mais c'est pas qu'ils ont une majorité
assez faible c'est que il est battu
régulièrement il a été deux fois de
suite dans le cadre du budget c'est pas
rien d'être battu quand on est
majoritaire
que vous lui MP vous seriez prêt
aujourd'hui à gouverner ou pas bah ça
veut dire qu'il faut que nous nous y
préparions
c'est une certitude scénario qui n'est
pas le scénario favori il y a d'autres
priorités pour les Français mais en tout
cas il faut que nous soyons prêts
c'était d'ailleurs l'esprit du séminaire
que nous avons organisé au mois de
décembre sur les questions économiques
en disant c'est bien gentil de critiquer
c'est bien gentil de faire des
propositions comme ça mais vous si vous
étiez au responsabilité qu'est-ce que
vous feriez mais nous avons fait un
certain nombre de propositions qui sont
opérationnels immédiatement et nous
avons un plan d'urgence pour redresser
le pays voilà donc il faut nous y
préparer je pense que
c'est quand on est éventuellement mais
quand on est responsable politique on
doit se préparer à gouverner nous sommes
un parti d'alternance donc l'échéance
normale et prévu en 2017 s'il y a des
circonstances exceptionnelles nous
devons nous préparer alors justement ces
conseillers de l'ombre vous avez sans
doute entendu leur nom c'est le plus de
cette semaine
jeux d'influence les stratèges de la
communication de luckermann et Gilles
boveau c'est le titre d'un documentaire
sur les conseillers en communication des
hommes politiques qui sont-ils quelle
est leur pouvoir un documentaire diffusé
sur France 5 le 6 mai mais si mon
barbarie nous livre un aperçu en
avant-première
on ne les voit pas on ne les entend pas
et pourtant ce sont leurs messages que
reprennent régulièrement les
journalistes les conseillers ont
communication se sont imposés dans
toutes les sphères du pouvoir le
documentaire jeu d'influence diffusé sur
France 5 le 6 mai prochain donne un coup
de projecteur sur ses hommes de l'ombre
les auteurs luckermann et Gilles bovon
sont allés à la rencontre de ces
stratèges de la communication leurs
échecs leur succès et surtout leur
gestion de crise sont issues
décortiquées dans une crise si vous
commencez à être en retard le premier
jour en règle générale vous allez pas
être performant sur l'ensemble de la
crise le début est décisif donc cette
idée de considérer que ça va passer que
ça va s'arranger tout seul non quand il
y a des situations de crise il faut y
faire face dans l'urgence si les
communicants peuvent imposer subtilement
des thèmes à l'agenda médiatique ils
peuvent aussi effectuer des pressions
déguisées sur les journalistes lors de
l'affaire Cahuzac c'est par téléphone
que le communicant Stéphane Fuchs a
tenté d'influencer le journaliste de
media Fabrice harfy
vous avez très bonne réputation sur la
place de Paris vous savez Fabrice il
faudrait pas que votre carrière empathie
on a déjà vu des grands journalistes se
tromper il faudrait pas que ça vous
arrive Fabrice en fait dans cette
conversation on se rend compte qu'il a
déjà les premiers ingrédients de ce qui
deviendra plus tard la riposte
médiatique de Jérôme Cahuzac ce
documentaire mais aussi le doigt sur les
passages alternés de ces hommes de
l'ombre dans les ministères et dans les
grandes entreprises et sur les soupçons
de conflits d'intérêt qui accompagnent
de telles allers-retours on laissera le
mot de la fin à Stephen Fuchs
d'intérêt puisqu'on a décidé de plus
prendre aucun contrat de conseil avec
les ministres donc au moins le problème
a été réglé nettoyé pourquoi cette
décision a été prise parce que c'était
1% du business et 99% des emmerdes et
qu'il faut savoir dire stop
on l'a entendu 99% des emmerdes les
hommes politiques pour s'exprime doctor
est-ce qu'ils sont devenus
indispensables aujourd'hui aux hommes
politiques
je ne dirais pas cela je dirais que je
joue au début de l'émission je vous
disais que c'est important pour un homme
politique en tout cas c'est ma
conviction de s'entourer d'avis éclairée
c'est-à-dire d'avoir des gens qui vous
permettent de sortir un peu de votre
monde et puis d'élargir le débat la
discussion donc oui il y a des avis
entre guillemets éclairés qui sont
utiles et je retiens une chose
importante dans ce qu'a dit Jean-Luc
mano j'ai appris cela au gouvernement
j'ai appris ça de Nicolas Sarkozy c'est
quand vous avez une crise il faut pas
croire que vous allez passer entre les
gouttes voilà et donc c'est la théorie
du cyclone de Nicolas Sarkozy vous savez
quand il y a un cyclone qui arrive le
seul endroit qui est calme c'est l'oeil
du cyclone il faut aller dans l'oeil du
cyclone et il faut affronter le problème
de face et c'est vrai que en matière de
communication c'est très important si
vous avez donné l'impression de fuir de
ne pas être à l'aise même si vous êtes
dans votre droit même si vous des mais
si vous défendez mal on a vu des hommes
politiques qui étaient tout à fait
sincères et honnêtes mal se défendre et
dans l'opinion finalement on avait
l'impression qu'ils probable donc ils
ont plutôt une bonne influence sur les
politiques
à traiter avec modération avec
modération il y a un exemple aussi qui
est pas cité dans le documentaire c'est
Franck Louviers qui le donne c'est aussi
cette influence qui peut avoir sur les
journalistes un coup de SMS et on dit
voilà l'actualité finalement elle se
fait là on serait si influent que ça
mais c'est d'abord
moi je pense que c'est plus que de
l'influence c'est simplement de la
transparence de l'information vous les
journalistes vous êtes à l'affût à juste
titre de l'information donc vous
cherchez par différents canaux à
récupérer l'information
ça récent directement dans un politique
mais aussi évidemment en parlant à la
conseiller à leur entourage donc les
conseillers qu'est-ce qu'ils font bah
ils nourrissent les journalistes
informations et maintenant de leur
patron ou leur permettant vous
permettant d'interpréter
le problème qu'il y a aussi de
crédibilité pour les politiques pour les
journalistes parce qu'on est tous un peu
dans le même sac finalement on a un
problème de crédibilité aux yeux de
l'opinion publique c'est peut-être ça
qu'ils le problème je pourquoi on a un
problème de crédibilité parce que les
Français sont désabusés des discours
sans résultat et des promesses vaines
c'est-à-dire que ce qui ne supporte plus
c'est ce qui a été la mode à un moment
c'est l'artifice c'est le plan de com
alors qu'il n'y a pas de fond derrière
la communication elle doit être au
service de la Parole mais au service de
l'action c'est ça qui est important elle
doit permettre à faire c'est très
important dans une j'ai fait du dans une
autre vie du marketing dans la grande
consommation
c'est très bien d'avoir la meilleure pub
du monde mais si vous n'avez pas un bon
produit ça marchera jamais ça vendra
jamais passer pareil qu'un homme
politique merci en tout cas Luc Chatel
d'être venu dans Parlement Hebdo on se
retrouve bientôt dans quelques semaines
on va laisser passer quelques jours
notamment du
mois de mai etc la semaine prochaine